what confuses a new screenwriter the
most I think it's voice on the page
it is
selecting a word choice that captures
tone and style and develop developing
their original voice on the page
um
it's a big thing it is not totally
quantifiable I mean it's you can't
really teach someone their voice it's
literally which words do you choose in a
description paragraph to capture the
moment
and I think new writers don't quite get
how important tone is how important it
is to capture the style and tone of a
moment of an individual scene or even
just a second of screen time
they should think
as if they're watching that movie or TV
show at that moment what would the what
would the audience feel in that moment
and then try and recreate that with
words on the page it might apply to
paragraph breaks it might punctuation
might help white Space versus text
everything adds up to
creating the tone of that particular
scene and the pace and the style
and you can't fully teach that but I can
give them enough notes and even like
edits and I can say here's how you might
rewrite this description maybe if you
were use a word that's a little bit
stronger here this one seems a little
flat I can push them in that direction
and then hopefully they'll they'll get
into the groove and feel their voice on
the page and it'll get to be second
second hand
do you ever have a writer think that
they have a distinct voice but it turns
out they're really emulating their
favorite author or screenwriter it
happens it happens
um like I've had writers uh write like
really staccato short
description lines and it's kind of just
like too much you know it's too choppy
so you know the opposite of that is
those big thick description paragraphs
you don't want those either but you do
want kind of a balance between
you know
um smaller description paragraph maybe
just one line of description maybe a
bigger one you know use white space It
should flow you don't want too long of
monologues in your dialogue
um it is hard to quantify but the page a
good comedy page feels different and
maybe even looks different than a good
uh biopic page you know what are the
biggest mistakes you see made over and
over again in screenplays
I would say not capturing tone
the tone of the scene in both
description and dialogue
having characters not have distinctive
voices in their dialogue
too long
pacing's too slow
on the nose dialogue
not getting us into the story as fast as
possible because when that reader starts
your script from the get-go they want to
know what the story is
what what is the concept what is the
engine what am I watching and it doesn't
mean you have to launch the engine
at the bottom of page one of course you
can let it play out
and take some time and surprise us but
just know that
you can't have 30 pages of just set up
before you even introduce any of the
main uh engines or main story elements
you know
we're looking for what makes this unique
and what is the journey we're going to
follow
can you explain what engine means an
engine is a character pursuing a goal
against obstacles
and
it's preceded usually by a catalyst so
they're thrown into a situation in which
they're now pursuing a goal and there
are antagonistic forces against them
it usually your goals internal and
external those are both engines so will
the hero defeat the villain that's your
external engine you know they're they're
fighting to catch the villain and the
villain is fighting against them or
there's other factors in the way
obstacles and then external will they
reunite with their spouse okay so that's
more of an emotional maybe romantic
engine but it's still an engine they
want to win back their spouse and there
are obstacles in between you know so you
can call that an engine what's driving
the story
with a TV series I like to define the
compelling crisis which is like the core
of the drama it's the core problem that
that show is
showcasing and it's usually an engine
it's will this character achieve this
you know against these obstacles it's
kind of a mini log line if you will
um
so you want to know what that core Crux
problem is you probably want one in in a
in a pilot you want an A and A B story
definitely you might have a c and a d
you probably don't want to have
you know also an E F G H I J story you
don't want to have too many engines
going
unless it's a
multi-character piece like White Lotus
like the White Lotus but even there I
think you really only have four separate
engines four separate camps you know
with the different characters
um
I think in season two maybe they added
there were more characters there was
more going on but that's a specific type
of story and it's an ensemble piece it's
a multi-character
and those are tougher to write but that
is a route you could go can we Define
what tone is can we give an example
tone in screenplays is really word
choice
to create the feeling of a scene and
it's hard to quantify because
there's you know a billion words you
could use to capture a certain scene and
that's really the Special Sauce that the
writer brings what words punctuation
black versus white space on the page are
they going to use to capture that tone
but um
if you think of I mean so something like
get out which has a creepy scary tone
that's probably going to look different
on the page than
you know as good as it gets
um
and it's hard it depends on the example
of course but I'm always
um
trying to help my writers with the tone
in the page just saying
you know if this is horror or should we
be scared right now should we not and
sometimes with newer writers it's hard
to tell you know they're using different
they're using kind of maybe more
matter-of-fact words when I when I I'll
say well maybe use stronger words maybe
cut this sentence off with a dash and so
what's coming next will feel more abrupt
and maybe we picture it on our head
different you know I've always have
the projector going in my head I'm
always picturing the scenes you know
playing on the screen as anyone does
when they're reading a screenplay they
should be you know you're picturing the
movie or the TV show that's playing out
so
you want them to picture it as
much as close as possible to your
version of the movie you know
um that's impossible to do and that's
why you don't want to direct on the page
you don't want to use directorial terms
you know pan left and and close up
extreme close-up
um you don't want to write like the
director like right camera references
because really you can't you can't
explain how a scene looks or how a shot
looks you know you couldn't really if I
explained
um
a shot of a desert it doesn't mean you
would think of it exactly like it
appeared in Lawrence of Arabia you know
we would have different thoughts about
what that desert shot looked like so you
don't want to try that much go that far
to over explain
but word choice is really really
important and tone and feeling uh
Spielberg always said
when he's listening to a pitch he says
what is the audience feeling now you
know so I want to know
how it would feel if I was the audience
member of this script I'm reading
so if I'm reading a script let's say for
the swingers and I don't really know the
movie versus The Hangover the two tones
are definitely getting even though
there's like a similarity with some of
it not totally but there's going to be
an obvious difference in this tone if it
really works I'm going to feel a
different there should be yeah yeah I
mean those are both comedies so maybe
those are a little close but um
uh the cone if you look at Coen Brothers
scripts No Country for Old Men has some
really interesting kind of literary text
they use a lot of
kind of more lofty language in their
descriptions than you would normally use
in a script and they use a lot of
description
um
more than I think probably a new
unestablished writer should use but if
you get a chance to read No Country for
Old Men that's really interesting
Whiplash by Damien chazelle that has
some really interesting tonal
choices
yeah it's all about uh
the words that you choose that's writing
can you tell the difference between a
screenplay where the goal is just to
sell it versus the goal is to tell a
compelling story
so uh usually the one that they're only
writing because they want to sell it you
just don't feel passion for the story
it's usually flatter it's just written
flatter
there might be elements thrown in that
come out of nowhere they're not
motivated I mean motivation is huge and
I feel like
it gets more and more important for me
the more scripts I read more books I
read and the more movies I watch
um
the more motivated actions are in a
script
just the better I don't know why but uh
film is a visual medium and you want to
see
um
if your character does something or they
come upon something we kind of want
set up for it we want to have something
be motivated we want to know we want to
know why or how they got to this point
and a lot of beginner screenplays it's
too random it's not necessarily
motivated I hear a lot of screenwriters
tell me but this happened to me in real
life this just random thing happened to
me in real life that happens right well
movies and TV shows aren't random
dramatic visual storytelling is not
random as an audience we do want to see
why something happens we want to see the
setup of it you know breadcrumbs leading
up to the reveal uh setups before
payoffs
lighting the bomb before the bomb goes
off
so
motivation and setup are very key
they're left out of a lot of modern work
I think too much I find that I'm too
confused when I watch especially a lot
of newer films they throw you into the
story too fast we're entering the story
too late and we have to catch up and put
together what's going on who are these
people
is that their job where are they you
know you don't want to start off with
your audience confused
you know they can be
interested and compelled to find out
more but if they're confused and they
just don't know what the hell's going on
that's not a good place to be anywhere
in the script